The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I'd like to
continue with our discussion
of the methods of solution for
the finite element equations
that we are encountering in
non-linear dynamic analysis.
In the previous lecture,
I pointed out that the
techniques used for the solution
of these finite
element equations in non-linear
dynamic analysis
can be classified as data
integration techniques,
methods of multiple position,
and substructuring.
We talked in the previous
lecture about these types of
methods, and in particular,
we discussed in detail an
explicit integration method,
namely the central difference
method, and an implicit
integration method, namely the
trapezoidal rule.
We talked about how these
methods are applied, how time
steps might be selected, what
the restrictions of these
methods are, and so on.
I'd like to now in this lecture
discuss with you the
method of multiple position,
and also
substructuring technique.
After the discussion off these
two techniques, I'd like to
talk with you about
some examples.
As a first example, we want
to consider the wave
propagation in a rod.
As a second example, I'd like to
share with you experiences
regarding the response of a 3
degree of freedom system.
As a third example, then, we
want to consider the analysis
of a 10-story tapered tower.
Example 3 and example 1 are
really solutions of a linear
system, but we learn quite a
bit, even regarding non-linear
analysis, from these examples.
As the fourth example, then,
I'd like to share with you
experiences obtained in the
analysis of a pendulum that
goes through very large
displacement.
As a fifth example, then, we
consider the pipe whip
response solution.
This is of much practical
interest.
And after these examples,
which I've prepared view
graphs for, I'd like to consider
with you some slides.
On these slides, we will have
the analysis of a control rod
drive housing with the response
of a spherical cap, a
highly non-linear problem,
large displacement,
elastoplastic response, and then
the analysis of a fluid
structure interaction problem,
a pipe test in which we are
comparing our computer's
results with
experimental results.
I should point out right now
that the details regarding
these example solutions are
given in some papers that I
had also earlier.
And please look at the study
guide, where the references to
these papers are given.
Let me now walk over here to
the view graph that we have
prepared regarding
this lecture.
And the first method of solution
that I wanted to
discuss with you is the method
of multiple position.
Quite a number of you probably
have used this technique
already in linear analysis.
In fact, the word
"superposition" somehow
implies that you are dealing
with a linear analysis.
However, we can extend that
method directly to non-linear
analysis if we recognize that
the mode shape vectors of the
system at a particular time
can be used as generalized
displacements, or basis vectors,
to express the
response to any other
time, as well.
The method is effective when,
in non-linear analysis, the
response lies in only a few
vibration modes, just the same
way as we are applying multiple
position also in
linear analysis, namely, it's
only effective really when a
few vibration modes capture the
total dynamic response.
The same holds here, of course,
in non-linear analysis.
And when the system has
possibly only local
non-linearities.
Let's look at is equations
that we're using in this
multiple position technique.
The basic starting point are
the equations that we have
seen before regarding
dynamic analysis.
But notice in this particular
equation, I have assumed now
that the damping matrix is not
present, so we have no damping
in the system coming from
the damping matrix.
There could, of course, be
damping due to the material
non-linearities, which
are captured in
the K and the F matrix.
Well, this is the
set of equations
that we want to solve.
And usually, we just iterate on
these equations until the
right-hand side is 0, where of
course we also would bring
this one here onto the
right-hand side.
So think of this one here as a
minus on the right-hand side,
and if, then, this right-hand
side, with M on that
right-hand side is 0, meaning
the data UK is 0, no more
updating to the incremental
displacements, then we have
established equilibrium
configuration corresponding to
time t, of course, including
inertia effects.
In multiple position, we don't
want to directly to deal with
these equations in this form.
Instead, we want to transform
them into a new form, and into
a form such that we obtain less
unknowns to deal with.
Let's assume for the moment that
tau is equal to 0 so that
we are dealing with the solution
of the equations
using the initial
stress method.
We talked about initial stress
method in an earlier lecture.
Then using this transformation
here, where phi R are the
eigenvectors of this problem
down here, And the xi are the
generalized displacements
corresponding to these
eigenvectors.
Notice this equation is exactly
the same that we're
used to seeing in
linear analysis.
Of course, in linear analysis,
we are usually not putting
this t plus delta t up there.
It's understood that the time
dependency is in xi, but the
space dependency is in phi i.
And notice we are summing
here from r to s.
r would have to be selected
by the analyst,
and s the same way.
Having introduced this
transformation with this
eigenvalue problem here, and
substituting for the U
displacements in the general
equilibrium equation, and
using the same approach as
we are used to in linear
analysis, we directly obtain
this set of equations.
Now, notice here that in this
vector x double dot, and in
this vector x, delta meaning
increment, we have only the
components corresponding to the
r mode up to the s mode.
These are the generalized
displacements corresponding to
phi r up to phi s.
Here we have phi r to
phi s listed in this
matrix, capital phi.
Lower-case phi for these here.
These are the columns in this
matrix that is denoted as a
capital phi.
Notice here we define an omega
squared matrix, 0 elements in
the off-diagonals.
And on the diagonal, we have the
frequencies of the system,
of the actually linear system,
because we use 0K in the
eigenvalue solution.
These are the entries for
this equation up here.
And notice that we have now here
much less equations than
the total number of finite
element degrees of freedom.
Typically, r might be 1, s might
be 20, and then we would
have 20 equations here,
20 equations only.
Of course, r could also be 25,
and s 30, in which case we
have here a multiple position
corresponding to the 25th up
to the 30th mode.
In any case, in general, we will
have much less equations
then finite element degrees of
freedom that are listed, for
example, in this vector
here, R, I should say.
The externally applied load
corresponding to these degrees
of freedom are listed in here.
Of course, the F vector is the
vector of nodal point forces
corresponding to the element
stresses at time t plus delta
t, and at the end of iteration,
k minus 1.
This matrix times that vector
gives us a vector which has
the same length as this vector
has and that vector has.
So we are not dealing anymore
with all the degrees of
freedom that are listed for
which we have the forces here
in the solution of the equation,
but with much less
degrees of freedom, the degrees
of freedom being equal
to the number of mode shapes
that are being employed.
An interesting and most
important point is that in
non-linear analysis, we have a
coupling, due to this vector
appearing in here, between
the different mode shape
equations, or modal equations.
We cannot solve, as we usually
do in linear analysis, one
equation of the modes of a
position after the other.
In linear analysis, you would
typically solve the dynamic
response equation in mode 1,
then the one in mode 2, then
the one in mode 3, and like
that, you'd sweep over all the
generalized degrees of freedom,
one after the other,
for the total response from
time 0 to the end of the
response time that you're
interested in.
In non-linear analysis, we have
to go step by step still
forward in time, solving all
equations, all modal equations
at time t, then all modal
equations at time t plus delta
t, then at time t plus 2 delta
t, and so on, because there is
this coupling, and because we
don't know f unless we have
all the information coming
from all the mode shapes.
Well, a typical problem that you
might want to solve with
this approach is the
pipe whip problem.
Here we have a very long,
slender pipe.
There is here a restraint
that has a gap.
And suddenly, this end of the
pipe is subjected to a very
large force.
The pipe undergoes dynamic
motion, a wave travels along
here, goes plastic, hits
this stop, et cetera.
It's a very complicated problem,
and this approach of
multiple position is it cheap
way of obtaining a solution to
this problem.
Of course, the accuracy of the
solution depends on how many
mode shapes you include.
If you only include a few mode
shapes, the solution is quite
inexpensive, but the accuracy
is not very high.
If you include as many mode
shapes as there are finite
element degrees of freedom,
then of course you get the
exact response.
All you have done is transformed
from one basis,
the finite element degrees of
freedom basis, to the mode
shape basis.
But then, of course, the
solution is very expensive,
and you don't want to
ever do is that.
The point is that you want to
perform such analysis if you
only need to include
a few modes in
the response solution.
We would actually look at this
problem, or such a problem, a
little later, when we discuss
example analyses.
As a second technique that can
also be very useful in
non-linear dynamic analysis, I'd
like to discuss with you
the substructuring technique.
This procedure is used is
implicit time integration, and
the important aspect is that
prior to the analysis, we are
setting u this effective
stiffness matrix corresponding
to the linear degrees of freedom
only, and we are
statically condensing out all
the degrees of freedom that
will remain linear throughout
the response solution.
It is quite effective for
local non-linearities.
Here, for example, we have a
tower structure, and the only
non-linearity that this
structure sees, say, is the
slip down here.
This typically would mean that
we have a large number of
linear degrees of freedom that
we can deal with very
effectively, using the
substructuring approach.
The non-linear degrees of
freedom here, of course,
require iteration and updating
of matrices, and those we deal
with in the usual way.
Let me show you in more detail
what I mean here.
Let's look schematically
at an example.
Here we have a 10-story
building, and that 10-story
building is discretized,
idealized, as shown here.
We also want to include the
elasticity of the foundation,
and that is modeled very simply
here as an assemblage
of springs.
We deal here with two
substructures, shown in red
for the substructure degrees
of freedom and in black for
the master degrees of freedom.
This is also part of the master
degrees of freedom.
Notice that here we have
one substructure--
in other words, this part here
is nothing else than that part
right here.
That's what is one
substructure.
And of course, you see here
another substructure.
But we have a repetition here--
in other words, this
substructure here is identically
equal to that
substructure.
This, of course, is the fact
because of the particular
design of this building.
The upper stories look the same
way as the lower stories.
That's the reason why we can
say, this is one substructure
model which can model this part
of the structure and that
part of the structure,
as well.
If we look at the stiffness
matrix, or the effective
stiffness matrix of this
structure that he would
encounter in a direct
integration solution using
implicit time integration,
schematically, we see the following.
Notice here we have the entries
coming from the
substructures, and here
we have entries
from the master structure.
This coupling here corresponds
also to master degrees of
freedom, and similarly, this
coupling corresponds to master
degrees of freedom.
Here we have the displacement
vector, the incremental
displacement vector.
And let's see here that these
master degrees of freedom of
course correspond to these
element entries here.
These master degrees of freedom
correspond to these
entries, and these master
degrees of freedom correspond
to these entries.
Now what we can do is condense
out all the linear degrees of
freedom effects.
And that is achieved
as follows.
We recognize that the total
effective stiffness matrix
corresponding to time t is made
up of this part here,
which is the linear stiffness
matrix plus
the total mass matrix.
I should point out here that
this K matrix contains all the
linear contributions, where that
M matrix here corresponds
to all the contributions from
the masses at the master
degrees of freedom and the
substructure degrees of freedom.
Because we're assuming here that
the total mass matrix is
linear, we can put all the mass
effects right in there.
And then since this is not the
total effect of stiffness, we
add the effect of the
non-linear element
stiffnesses, right here.
And in this particular analysis,
this might be, for
example, the non-linear
springs down there.
The non-linear springs modelling
the foundation on
the structure.
Well, this can be written
in this form.
And if we perform static
condensation on this combined
matrix, we arrive at
this matrix here.
Notice here we have a condensed
degree of freedom
vector carrying only the master
degrees of freedom, and
here we have the entries
corresponding to the master
degrees of freedom in
the tK hat matrix.
We put a c on there,
meaning condensed.
After static condensation,
this is a matrix
that has been reached.
These black squares here
correspond to as the black
squares that you saw earlier.
Of course, they have now been
changed a bit because of the
static condensation, because
the effect of the linear
degrees of freedom have
been carried into
these entries here.
The major steps in the solution
are as follows.
Prior to the step-by-step
solution, we establish the K
hat, the linear effective
stiffness matrix containing K
plus 4 over delta t squared m.
And this K hat matrix is then
used to statically condense
out all internal substructure
degrees of freedom to obtain
this K hat c, c standing
for condensed matrix.
We note that the actual
effective stiffness matrix
including the non-linear effects
is then obtained by
taking the linear effective
stiffness matrix and adding
the non-linear stiffness
effects to it.
Notice, once again, this matrix
is obtained from this
matrix here, as I mentioned
earlier.
We use this matrix to statically
condense out all
the linear degrees of freedom.
The solution is then obtained in
each time step as follows.
We update the condensed
matrix K hat c--
there should be no t here--
K hat c for non-linearities.
That means we're adding the tK
matrix to it, corresponding to
the non-linearities that have
occurred in the system.
We establish the complete load
vector for all degrees of
freedom, and condense out the
substructure internal degrees
of freedom.
This is important
to recognize.
We have to calculate the
complete load vector because
of the intertia effects on the
internal substructure degrees
of freedom.
The intertia forces on the
internal substructure degrees
of freedom carry forces to the
master degrees of freedom that
we have to take into account in
each time step and in each
equilibrium iteration.
We then solve for the master
degrees of freedom, using the
small system size, the tK
hat c, the velocities,
accelerations, and calculate all
the substructural degrees
of freedom--
velocities, displacements,
and accelerations.
These are required here to
calculate the load vector
corresponding to all
degrees of freedom.
Schematically, the solution
procedure, therefore, proceeds
as follows.
For each time step and each
iteration, we start with the
displacement velocities and
accelerations at time t.
We calculate the effective load
vector, corresponding to
time t plus delta t,
the way I've been
talking about it earlier.
And then we condense that load
vector, as shown here, to the
condensed load vector, c
meaning condensation.
We then, from this load vector,
calculate with the
effective tension stiffness
matrix, the t plus delta t Uc
vector, and this vector is
used to calculate the
displacement, velocity, and
accelerations of all the
degrees of freedom at
time t plus delta t.
Of course here I'm showing
only the process for a
typical time step.
If you iterate, as we usually do
in non-linear analysis, of
course, then you would have to
also introduce the iteration
counter here in these vectors.
Notice that using this solution
procedure, we get the
same results as if we had not
performed the substructuring.
In other words, there is no
additional assumption that
we're introducing into
the solution.
You get the same results.
However, the solution cost is
reduced, because we are
dealing with one substructure,
a typical substructure, only
once regarding the
factorization--
the LDL transpose factorization
and static
condensation that has
to be performed.
Let us now look at some
example solutions.
And the first example that I'd
like to consider with you is
the solution of the wave
propagation in a rod.
Here we have a uniform freely
floating rod, and we apply to
the left end of that rod a force
that varies as shown
here as step load
of 1000 newtons.
The material data for the
rod are given here.
We want to perform a linear
elastic analysis, but although
this is a linear analysis, we
still will learn quite a bit
from it regarding non-linear
analysis.
We want to consider the
compressive force at a point
at the center of the
rod, right there.
And the exact solution for this
force at that point is
plotted here.
You have, once again, apply 1000
newtons, and here we have
the time scale.
Notice up to 1/2 t star, there's
no force at point a,
because the applied force
in fact has to
propagate through the rod.
Then we have the full force up
to 3/2 t star, and then no
force again, where t star is the
time for the stress waves
to travel through the
complete rod.
This is the analytical
solution, well-known,
well-established, and we want to
compare with this solution
when we perform our finite
element analysis.
For the finite element analysis,
we use a mesh off
2-noded truss elements, as shown
here, and we measure the
force at the midpoint of the
total structure by the
compressive force
in this element.
We use in this analysis first
essential difference method,
and recognize that the time
step that we use has to be
small or equal to the critical
time step, as we discussed in
the previous lecture.
And that critical time step
is given by Le/c.
Please refer to as the previous
lecture notes, and
you would see this formula
there, which is nothing else
than t star divided by the
number of elements.
We recall that if delta t is
greater than delta t critical,
we would produce an
unstable solution.
We also need to deal
with the initial
conditions for this problem.
And we recognize that if the
initial displacements are 0
and R is given, then we can
calculate the initial
acceleration, as shown here.
Using now a time step equal to
the critical time step, we
obtain the correct result, and
I pointed that out in the
earlier lecture already, that
we in fact obtain the exact
solution for any number
of finite elements
to model the rod.
And here is a finite element
solution, compared with the
exact solution.
A wonderful solution, right
on the exact solution.
Using, however, now a
smaller time step--
and this is frequently
of surprise--
using a smaller time step, we
get a much worse result.
Here we use a time step of
1/2 delta t critical.
Half the time step that
we used before.
And just solution looks actually
very bad right here.
Frequently one sort of
intuitively thinks, well, if I
use a smaller time step, I
should get better results.
My costs go up, and surely I
Well, it turns out that using
the explicit time integration
scheme for this type of problem,
this wave propagation
problem, with a smaller time
step, more cost, higher cost,
you get worse results.
That is really something
to keep in mind.
Now let us consider the
trapezoidal rule.
The trapezoidal rule-- we
discussed this method in the
earlier lecture.
And I'd like to refer you
once again to the notes
corresponding to that lecture,
where we have identified that
a stable solution would
be obtained with any
choice of delta t.
Remember, this is a linear
analysis, and the trapezoidal
rule is unconditionally
stable.
We could use a consistent
or lumped mass matrix.
And in this particular case, we
use a lumped mass matrix,
because we also like to compare
our results with those
that we obtained using the
central difference method.
If we use the trapezoidal rule
with the time step that we
employ in the central
difference method--
in fact, the critical time
step that we used there--
and we also use the initial
conditions computed as shown
here, the way we did it for the
central difference method
solution, we find that the
solution is very inaccurate
when compared to the
exact solution.
Here, of course, we also use
the 10-element mesh.
If we use 0 initial conditions
for the trapezoidal rule, we
get this solution.
Not much different, really, from
the solution that I just
showed you.
So whether we use 0 initial
conditions or the initial
conditions corresponding to the
equation MU double dot is
equal to R, which we have seen
on the previous view graph,
makes very little difference
when using
the trapezoidal rule.
It makes a lot of difference
using the explicit central
difference method.
And for that reason, in fact,
we have to use the proper
initial conditions obtained from
MU double dot equals R at
time 0 when we use the central
difference method.
Using now twice the time step of
what we just used, namely,
delta t equal to 2 times delta
t, critical of the central
difference method, this solution
is stable, but very
inaccurate.
It is stable because we're
using an unconditionally
stable operator.
We discussed it in the
previous lectures.
Note that this is the solution
we're obtaining when compared
to the exact solution.
Now we look at the solution
where we have half the time
step off the critical size,
corresponding to the central
difference method.
And you see here, the solution,
again, very
inaccurate when compared to
the exact solution, but of
course stable, because the
method is always stable for
any time step delta t.
The question now could, of
course, be, and should be,
what happens if we take more
elements to discretize the
whole structure?
Here we use the 10-element
model.
Why not use more elements?
And here we now look at the
solution obtained with the
essential difference method when
we use 100 elements to
model the total bar.
Here the exact solution in red,
and that exact solution
is reached if you integrate the
equilibrium equations with
this time step.
We discussed that earlier.
That exact solution is always
obtained for any number of
elements that you use to
discretize a structure,
provided you use delta t equals
delta t critical.
If you then use a smaller time
step, in fact, delta t equals
1/2 delta t critical was used
here, we obtain a solution
that is not the exact solution,
but as you can see
here, it oscillates for this
time step this amount about
the exact solution.
So we have much the same
observations that we have seen
already earlier, namely, when
the time step is decreased in
the central difference
method solution--
from the critical time step,
here we see a decrease--
the solution that one might
expect to be better actually
deteriorates.
Of course, it couldn't
be better
than the exact solution.
But we see here a deterioration,
and a quite
significant one.
If you use the trapezoidal rule,
this is the solution
that you obtain with the time
step equal to the critical
time step of the central
difference method.
Again, here, we're using
the 100-element mesh.
The solution is certainly better
than what we have seen
for the 10-element mesh,
but it does not give
us the exact solution--
in other words, a
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] wavefront as
we would like to obtain.
Of course, this is a very
difficult problem to solve,
because we have infinitely steep
wave fronts here and
there, basically, to model.
And an overshoot would obviously
obtain it, but we
would like to have said
overshoot and undershoot, with
this oscillation here as small
as possible, of course, with
the solution scheme
that we employ.
There is one more important
consideration that I'd like to
bring to your attention.
Here we use a 2-dimensional
element mesh to model the bar.
Notice these are 4-node
elements, plane stress
elements here to
model the bar.
And in this particular
case, we use the
central difference methods.
The thickness is given
here, the material
data are given here.
For this solution, notice that
this distance here is half the
distance that we have here.
And that is something that leads
to a phenomenon that one
has to be aware of.
Notice our the critical time
step that we identified for
the one-dimensional wave
propagation here would, of
course, be calculated depending
on this length.
However, we have to allow for
the fact that there is also a
possibility of wave propagation
this way, and the
actual critical time step that
we have to use in this problem
is given by this length, by the
shortest element distance.
Please refer to the previous
lecture, in which I discussed
this already.
You have to use the shortest
distance between nodal points
within an element to determine
the critical time step.
So this relationship here does
not hold anymore, because this
distance is less than that.
And if you were to use delta
t equal to t star over 10
elements, which was a critical
time step that we used when we
solved the truss element model,
then we would find that
the solution diverges.
In fact, in element 5, which was
the element that we always
used to measure our stress, we
find that tau zz, the absolute
value of tau zz, is greater than
1000 newtons divided by
the area at this time.
Notice that it was 1000 newton
that we applied.
So a stress that should be 0,
really, because tau zz should
really be 0, it's the stress in
the transverse direction,
the wave travels this way, and
tau zz is acting that way.
This stress should be 0.
We find, actually, that it
grows, and it grows because we
are using a time step that is
larger than the critical time
step that should be used
for this problem.
Let us now look at another
example, a second example from
which we can also learn
quite a bit.
Here we have a very simple 3
degree of freedom system.
These are the degrees of
freedom, x1, x2, x3.
Notice we have masses m here,
and we have a linear spring
connecting these masses, a
non-linear spring connecting
these masses, and a linear
spring connecting this mass to
the rigid support.
For this problem, the linear
spring has is distance here,
and the non-linear spring is
characterized by this force
displacement relationship.
Notice there's a kink
going from 1 to 100.
So the spring gets suddenly, at
a particular distance, or
rather deformations,
I should say--
displacement x2 minus x3--
at a particular deformation, the
spring becomes 100 times
as stiff as prior
to that point.
Well, we can calculate a
critical time step based on
this spring stiffness here, the
linear part, or rather,
this spring stiffness for
small displacements.
And that critical time step for
this problem is given as
1.11 seconds.
As long as the response of this
system is such that we
would, in this non-linear
spring, never go around this
kink, we would deal with a
linear system, and this would
be the proper critical
time step to use.
However, as soon as we are going
around this kink here,
due to the fact that the forces
that I applied, or the
initial conditions that we are
applying to these degrees of
freedom, are large enough, as
soon as we go around this
kink, our new critical time step
is based on this spring
stiffness, and if this given
right down here.
This is a new critical
time step.
So if we now perform essential
difference method solutions of
this problem, and if the
solution brings us into this
regime, it is very important
to use, as a critical time
step, 0.14 seconds.
It is very important, even if
we're only in this regime for
just a few steps.
You see, what might happen in
the response is that most of
the time, you're
in this regime.
But then all of a sudden, for
just a few steps, you're
getting into this regime,
and because of this high
stiffness, you're thrown
back into this regime.
If your time step that you use
in the time integration is
then larger than that value, you
are having an instability
for just these few time steps,
and that introduces an error
in the solution which, if you
don't have a comparison with
an exact analytical solution,
will of course be an error
that you not necessarily
will see, directly.
And that's one of the
important points.
You see, in linear analysis,
when you use the essential
difference method in linear
analysis with a time step that
is larger than the critical time
step, you will, after a
few time step integrations, see
that the response becomes
very large, and the instability
is obvious.
The instability is really
obvious when you apply the
central difference method with
a time step that is larger
than the critical time step to
the solution of the system.
However, in non-linear analysis,
as I mentioned in
the earlier lectures, and you
are now well aware of it, in
non-linear analysis, the
frequencies change.
The critical frequency being the
largest frequency in the
system changes.
The smallest period of the
system changes, as we are
seeing here in this
view graph, also.
And it is important that your
time step is always smaller
than the critical time step
based on the highest frequency
that you can ever encounter
in the solution.
If that is not the case, then
you might have only an
instability for a few time
steps, and the solution may
not have time to blow up,
or give you very large
displacements.
So the instability will
not be obvious.
Instead, the instability over
these few time steps only
introduces an error in the
solution, an error of which
you really don't know
the magnitude.
And after these few steps have
been completed, you're using
now a time step that
is again stable,
giving a stable solution.
That error which we have
accumulated, of course, is
carried forward, but
you have not seen a
blow-up of the solution.
And that's one important
consideration when you apply
the central difference method
in non-linear analysis.
Of course, the important point,
the sort of ground rule
that you have to observe, is
that delta t must always be
smaller than the critical time
step of the mesh where that
critical time step changes
throughout the solution.
Let's look at this
example here.
What happens if we violate
that condition?
I show you here the solution
with delta t equals 0.15
seconds, compared to
the solution with
delta t 0.05 seconds.
Notice that the response of the
right math here for both
of these time steps is slightly
different, but we can
say that for this time step,
we don't get displacements
that are very much different
than we obtain
with this time step.
If we look at the response of
the center mass, there are
more differences in
displacements.
And if we look at the response
of the left mass, in fact, we
have even larger differences.
But the important point is that
if you only have this
solution here corresponding to
the time step 0.15 seconds,
which is larger than the
critical time step, you would
certainly not expect that this
solution was unstable.
It in fact was only unstable
for a very few time steps.
There is an error accumulation,
fairly large here.
In fact, very large.
You can see that these
displacements are only about
50% of those displacements.
But you cannot see directly an
instability here if you don't
know this solution.
Let's look at the force
in the center truss.
Here we list the time, here we
list the solution for delta t,
0.05 seconds.
And here we list the solution
for delta t 0.15 seconds.
And you can see here that at
the beginning, the forces
compare quite well,
and then the error
becomes larger and larger.
In fact, here we have an
opposite sign in the force.
This being here, say, the
accurate solution with a small
enough time step, and this
being, of course, a grossly
inaccurate solution.
But it is not evident that this
is a grossly inaccurate
solution if you don't
know this solution.
And that's the point I wanted
to make with this example.
The next example that I like
to discuss with you Is the
analysis of a tower.
The tower is shown here,
subjected to a pressure that
is induced by a blast.
Here we have some geometric
and material data
regarding the tower.
The applied load on the
tower is shown here.
Notice it's a load that we
assume to be instantaneously
there, and then to decay,
as shown here, over 200
milliseconds.
The purpose of the analysis is
to determine the displacement
and velocities at the top off
the tower, to determine the
moments at the base
of the tower.
And in this particular
analysis, we use the
trapezoidal rule and the lumped
mass matrix to solve
the problem.
We must make a number of
decisions here, and two
decisions are most important.
We must choose a mesh that is,
in other words, we have to
establish an appropriate finite
element discretization
for the tower, and we have to
choose a time step for the
time integration.
The choice of mesh and the
choice of the time step are
two very closely related items,
and that's what I would
like to discuss with you in this
example in more depth.
Of course, the time step and the
mesh must both depend on
the loading that is supplied.
Let's look at some
observations.
The point is that the choice
of mesh will determines the
highest natural frequency, and
of course, the corresponding
mode shape, that is properly,
accurately represented in the
finite element analysis.
The more elements you use, just
as a rule of thumb, the
higher the frequency that can be
properly represented, that
can be accurately picked
up, with the choice
of mesh we're using.
The time step that you're using
will of course determine
how high a frequency you're
integrating accurately.
In other words, you want to use
really enough elements to
have a mesh that is accurate,
and you want to use is small
enough time step to integrate
the frequency of the mesh that
you need to integrate in order
to have an accurate response
prediction.
I used the word "accurate," and
we have to now of course
look closely at what
I mean by that.
It is most effective, really,
to choose the mesh and the
time step such that the highest
frequency, accurately
integrated, is equal to the
highest frequency accurately
represented by the mesh.
To choose the mesh and the
time step, we look at the
applied loading, in other words,
the physics of the
problem, and we represent
this applied loading
as a Fourier series.
If we do so, that Fourier
series will display the
important frequencies that are
to be accurately represented
by the mesh.
Here for this particular loading
that we're looking at,
we did a Fourier analysis, and
you can see that with this
Fourier analysis, we include
terms now in our first
analysis, in case one, up to fn
17 hertz, and in case two,
in our second analysis, up
fn equal to 30 hertz.
If we truncate our Fourier
representation of the loading
at 17 hertz, we obtain this
approximation here to the
actual applied noting.
If we truncate our Fourier
representation at 30 hertz, we
obtain this Fourier
approximation
to the actual loading.
As you can see, surely, as
expected, if you include more
terms in the Fourier
approximation, your
approximation to the actual
loading becomes better.
Now having identified that we
want to perform the analysis
with two meshes, first there's
a mesh that gives us
frequencies accurate up to 17
hertz, and then with a mesh
that is accurate up to 30 hertz,
we have to look for
those meshes.
And we do so by establishing
three meshes
that are shown here.
Here we have a 30-element
mesh.
Notice that one element spans
from the bottom of a floor to
the top off the floor,
and across from one
column to the other.
A 60-element mesh, in which we
simply have subdivided each
element here in this more coarse
mesh into two elements,
and a 120-element mesh, in which
we again have taken one
element here and represent
it as two elements.
We use these meshes here to
calculate frequencies.
And on this view graph here,
you see the frequencies
calculated for the 30-element
mesh and the 60-element mesh.
Notice mode numbers
in this column.
30-element mesh results here,
60-element mesh results here,
in each case, hertz.
We notice that up to this red
line, the difference between
the frequencies is less
than 1 hertz.
In other words, the difference
between the frequencies
obtained from the 30-element
mesh and the 60-element mesh
is less than 1 hertz, and
that is also right at
the 17 hertz level.
So we can say that the
30-element mesh really
represents the frequencies up to
17 hertz quite accurately.
You should also remember,
please, that since we are
using a lumped mass matrix in
the analysis, there's no
bounding theorem saying that
the frequencies of the
60-element mesh must always be
below the frequencies of the
30-element mesh.
For a larger mesh, we can
actually have frequencies that
are smaller or larger than
for the more coarse mesh.
That of course also applies
for when we compare the
60-element mesh result with
the 120-element mesh
result later on.
So we say that for the
30-element mesh, we have
accurately represented now the
frequencies up to 17 hertz,
and therefore, there
is the mesh to use.
We calculate the time step via
is this relationship here as
being 0.033 seconds, being the
cutoff frequency, and delta t
then is given here as
0.0017 seconds.
This mesh now should be
integrated with this time
step, and then we can say is
that the mesh up to 17 hertz
represents the frequencies quite
accurately, and we have
integrated the frequencies up to
17 hertz quite accurately,
and therefore, we have an
accurate solution of the
problem up to 17 hertz--
and what I mean by this "up to
17 hertz" is that also in the
Fourier representation, we in
effect only have represented
the load by the Fourier
representation up to
17 hertz, in effect.
Of course, in the actual
step-by-step solution, we also
will carry terms
above 17 hertz.
But these terms are assumed not
to contribute to very much
to the response, because we are
not picking them up very
well in the mesh and in the
time step selection.
If we proceed now with the same
ideas to also look at the
60-element mesh, then we
perform there also the
frequency analysis for the
60-element mesh and the
120-element mesh, and we find
that up to 30 hertz in the
60-element mesh, we gain
represent all the frequencies
accurately.
Notice that above the red line,
below these frequencies
here, the difference between
these frequencies
is less than 1 hertz.
Above this line, the difference
between the
frequencies is larger than
1 hertz, and that
is our cutoff line.
Well, if we want to perform
now the direct time
integration of the 60-element
mesh, we proceed as for the
30-element mesh.
We calculate our cut-off
frequency, our delta t, the
proper time step, 20 steps for
the highest frequency or the
smallest period that we want
to integrate accurately.
That's the rule of thumb
we're using.
And with this time step, we
perform the analysis.
Notice a smaller time step would
be accurately integrate
frequencies which are
not accurately
represented by the mesh.
Therefore, there is no point
choosing a smaller time step.
A larger time step would not
accurately integrate all
frequencies which
are accurately
represented by the mesh.
It is not good to choose a
larger time step, because your
mesh is chosen to represent the
frequencies up to 30 hertz
quite accurately, and to get all
of what you can get out of
the mesh, so to say, you want to
take a time step that is in
accordance selected
with the mesh.
And that times step selection
gives you this result here,
0.003 seconds.
Let's look now at the actual
response that is calculated.
Considering the horizontal
displacement at the top of the
tower, denoted as u, here,
we find that in fact the
30-element mesh and the
60-element mesh give virtually
the same response.
If we look at the horizontal
velocity at the top off the
tower, we find that there are
some small differences between
the 30-element and
60-element mesh.
If we were to look at the
accelerations, these
differences would of course
be even larger.
But the purpose of this analysis
was to calculate the
displacement and velocities
at the top of the tower.
Let's look at the moment, which
was also one requirement
for our analysis, the moment
right down here at the bottom
off the tower.
And here we see that the
30-element mesh gives the
smooth result.
The 60-element mesh gives
the zig-zagged result.
But overall, really, basically
a good response prediction
already with the 30-element
mesh.
If we look at the displacements
of the tower, we
have amplified these
displacements here.
The 30-element mesh at 200
millisecond looks like that.
The 60-element mesh.
looks like that.
At 400 milliseconds,
the 30-element mesh
looks as shown here.
The 60-element mesh looks
as shown there.
Regarding these analyses,
we now can
summarize some comments.
We saw some high-frequency
oscillations when we looked at
the moment reaction response
of the 60-element mesh.
However, this high-frequency
response, which actually can
be identified to be 110 hertz,
is probably inaccurate,
because our mesh did not
represent frequencies
accurately up to that level.
The obtained solutions for the
horizontal displacement and
the velocity at the top off the
tower are really virtually
identical for the 30- and
60- element mesh.
Let us now look at
another example.
This is the example
of a pendulum.
A large displacement analysis of
this pendulum is performed,
and basically what we're looking
at here is, if I can
just have your attention here,
is at the pendulum that
originally is horizontal,
it's pinned right here.
And we let this pendulum go
through very large motions,
and pendle around
as shown here.
If always should come back to
the horizontal position,
unless we have damping
in the system.
Since we don't have damping in
the system, the pendulum
should just keep on
going forever.
We have a frictionless hinge
right here, and this is
pictorially represented here
on the view graph, a
frictionless hinge
right there.
The pendulum is modelled by a
truss element of stiffness EA.
The length is given here.
The mass is concentrated
right there.
So there's no distributed
mass here.
All of the mass of the pendulum
is concentrated here,
half of it here, and
half of it there.
The initial conditions of the
pendulum are listed here.
The initial angle is 90 degrees
theta, so the pendulum
is up here, as I explained
already.
And initially, it
has 0 velocity.
And now we let the pendulum go,
and as I said, it should
spring up and down
here, of course,
under the gravity loading.
The dynamic response that we
want to calculate is obtained
using the trapezoidal rule.
And we are using full Newton
iterations to establish the
equilibrium during
every time step.
The convergence tolerance that
we use, and that I have to
refer you now to our earlier
view graph regarding
convergence tolerances.
The tolerance that we're using
here is ETOL equal to 10 to
the minus seventh.
We talked about what ETOL is
in an earlier lecture.
In our first analysis, we chose
the time step to be
equal to 0.1 seconds.
And in that case, the following
response is obtained here.
We expect that solution is shown
as a solid line, and
these circles here show
the calculated
finite element solution.
Notice 90 degrees theta here
minus 90 degrees here, and
then we return to 90 degrees.
The solution looks quite
fine, looks stable.
And in fact, if you look at the
textbook, you would find
that there I'm giving the
solution up to here.
Everything looks good.
However, if we plot the strain
in the truss, we find that at
larger times, the strain
oscillates very much, and in
fact, this oscillation grows.
This clearly signifies
an instability in
the solution process.
The instability is unchanged
when we tighten our
convergence tolerance or when we
use the BFGS method instead
of the full Newton method.
We should recall here that the
trapezoidal rule is only
unconditionally stable
in a linear analysis.
Here we are talking about a
non-linear analysis, and you
cannot select any time step
magnitude delta t and expect a
stable solution.
So what we have to do now is
to use a smaller time step,
and we choose delta t equal
to 0.025 seconds,
and repeat the analysis.
Theta degrees here as
a function of time.
And once again, a very nice,
smooth response solution,
starting with 90 degrees, going
to minus 90 degrees,
coming back to 90 degrees,
and so on.
Of course, even with a larger
time step, you got a smooth
solution for theta.
What really told us about the
instability in the solution
was our look at the strain
in the truss.
So we look now also at this
strain, and in this particular
case, with this time step,
we see a smooth
solution for the strain.
You should please observe that
the scale on the strain is
here different from the strain
scale that we had in the
earlier view graph.
If you refer back to the earlier
view graph, you see
that we had a different
scale there.
But we have a smooth solution
here, in fact, a solution the
way we would expect it.
If we don't iterate, then we
obtain a solution that looks
as shown here.
In other words, instead of
getting this oscillatory
response that we would like to
obtain, we obtain really a
highly damped solution
response.
This, of course, shows the
importance of iteration.
We have to iterate in the
solution of a dynamic problem.
It's very important to
integrate in order to
establish equilibrium for every
time step, for every
discrete time that we're
considering.
In this particular case, we see
that we obtained a highly
damped solution.
In other cases, the solution
might blow up.
So it is important to iterate
in the nonlinear dynamic
solutions when you
use an implicit
time integration scheme.
Although the solution obtained
with the equilibrium iteration
is highly inaccurate,
the solution
is, of course, stable.
And that is also seen when one
looks at the strain plot.
Notice here we're plotting
strains in the truss element
as a function of time.
No blow-up of that strain,
no violent oscillation.
It is, in fact, going up here,
and then becoming this rather
small oscillating,
as shown here.
So we don't have an unstable
solution, but a highly
inaccurate solution.
Let's look at the next example
now, the analysis of a pipe
whip problem.
Here we have a long pipe,
dimension given here and here,
that is subjected suddenly to a
concentrated load at its end.
There is also, below the
pipe, a restraint.
That restraint is only active
once this gap is closed.
Notice there is a 3-inch
gap here between the
pipe and the restraint.
Of course, this restraint, in
an engineering design, is
installed to prevent violent
emotions of the
pipe at this point.
What our objective here is,
to determine the transient
response of this pipe.
Notice that under this very
large load, the pipe very
rapidly becomes plastic.
And the difficulty of this
problem really lies in that
the pipe going plastic becomes
very flexible here, but the
restraint suddenly hitting the
pipe, or the pipe hitting the
restraint, rather, means that
a very large difference is
suddenly introduced
at this end.
The finite element model
we used is shown here.
6 summation beam elements that
of course can go plastic.
There's more of the
elastoplasticity
in the system properly.
And a truss element from
this node to that node.
This truss element contains
a 3-inch gap.
The material properties for
the pipes are listed here.
Notice the material property
corresponding to the
elastoplasticity.
We assume no strain hardening
and for the restraint.
Again, the restraint also
is modeled as an
elastoplastic material.
The analysis performed, in this
particular case, using
multiple position with two
modes and direct time
integration.
We want to compare the response
that we predict using
the multiple position procedure,
which I discussed
earlier in this lecture, with
the response that we obtain
using a time integration
analysis.
For the time integration
analysis, we use the
trapezoidal rule.
And in fact, even in the
multiple position, we also use
the trapezoidal rule.
And for the mass representation,
we have chosen
a consistent mass matrix.
In this particular case of
convergence tolerance, ETOL
was used with this
value down here.
If we perform the eigenvalue
solution of the initial
system, in other words, of the
elastic pipe in the initial
state, we obtain these natural
frequencies, 8.5
hertz and 53 hertz.
These are also the
mode shapes.
And of course, these frequencies
will change as
time progresses in the
elastoplastic response, and
also the mode shapes will
change, particularly once
their restraint is hit.
However, what we are saying is
that we believe we can capture
the elastoplastic response of
the pipe, approximately, by
using this mode shape and that
mode shape as generalized
displacement patterns
to represent
the total pipe response.
Of course, there are the heavy
approximations that we reduce
all of the pipe degrees
of freedom to adjust 2
generalized degrees
of freedom.
To integrate a response, we have
to choose a time step.
And here we have delta t 1/20
of the cutoff period that we
want to use here.
Notice that we have only two
modes in this problem that we
want to consider, with the
frequencies that I
showed you just now.
And this equation gives
us, as a time
step, 1/1000 of a second.
Of course, once again, this
estimate, or this choice of
time step, is based solely on
looking at the linear response
of the pipe.
In other words, assuming that
the pipe remains elastic and
that the restraint is
not there either.
If we look at the results
obtained from these two
analyses, we find that the
multiple position response for
the displacements looks as shown
here, the direct time
integration response looks
as shown here.
Notice that this is here the
distance of the gap, so at
this particular time, the gap
is closed and the restraint
comes into action.
We note from this graph that the
multiple position solution
is really very close to the
direct integration solution
for the displacement at
the tip off the pipe.
Now let us look at
the moment at the
built-in end of the pipe.
And here we have the moment
response plotted as a function
of time for the direct
integration solution, as shown
here, and for the multiple
position
solution, as shown here.
We notice that the maximum
moment occurring at the
built-in end in the pipe is
almost the same when predicted
by the multiple position
solution and the direct
integration solution.
There's some small difference,
but the difference is
certainly not very large.
However, if we look at what
happened at earlier times, we
see that there is a large
difference between the results
obtained using the multiple
position solution and the
direct integration solution.
The reason is that the response
here at earlier times
is very complex, and the
multiple position solution
cannot pick that complex
response up very well.
However, it's one important
point you should keep in mind.
And that is, if we had used
more modes in the multiple
position solution, we would come
closer to the response
obtained, predicted with the
direct integration solution.
In fact, if the number of modes
used in the multiple
position solution is equal to
the number of degrees of
freedom in the finite element
mesh, then the multiple
position solution gives you
the same response as you
calculate with the direct
integration solution.
I mentioned that earlier in the
lecture already, and the
reason, of course, is that in
that case, all you would have
done is a change of bases
from the finite element
displacements to the
mode shape bases.
So if you use, even with this
initial stiffness matrix that
you have used to calculate the
mode shapes, even with that
initial stiffness matrix, if
use all the modes, as many
modes as there are degrees of
freedom, in this multiple
position solution, you would
get the same response
prediction with the multiple
position solution as we're
seeing here, with the direct
integration solution.
And that means we can be quite
assured that as we increase
the number of modes in the
multiple position solution, we
will get closer and closer to
this complex response that is
predicted using the direct
integration solution.
In general, one, of course, does
not know the error when
you use the multiple position
solution, and there must
always be a question of how
large is the error, for
example, that we're
seeing here.
And that can only be assessed
by a more accurate solution.
However, I believe that's the
multiple position solution is
of much value in the initial
design analysis stages when
you want to obtain fairly
inexpensive solutions for the
response, and you want to just
understand how the system acts
that you are analyzing
and designing.
The multiple position solution
really yields relatively
inexpensive response solutions
of the system which may be
very helpful in the initial
design stages of that
structural system.
This completes, then, the
discussion of our examples for
which I have prepared
view graphs.
I'd like to now share with you
some further experiences that
are summarized on this slide.
And let me go over here,
where I have
the first slide projected.
I should point out, before we
discuss the information on
these slides once more, that
we will go fairly rapidly
through these slides, and that
not all details pertaining to
the solutions that we are
looking at here are given on
these slides.
Please refer to the papers--
the references are given in the
study guide-- in order to
find all of the details
pertaining to the solutions
that I'm now discussing
with the slides.
Here we consider now the
analysis of a control rod
drive housing, which is modelled
using four beam
elements and point masses.
Notice that the structure is
subjected to motion up here.
The non-linearity in the system
lies in the fact that
there's a gap between the tip
of that beam here and the
spring on the right-hand side
and on the left-hand side.
On the next slide, we see now
the solutions obtained.
We obtain a solution using
direct integration, and using
a multiple position analysis,
including two modes.
These two solutions are compared
with a solution that
was reported at some earlier
time by Peterson and myself.
Here you see the comparison
of the results obtained.
Notice there is a difference
here between the solution that
we reported earlier, that
Peterson and myself reported
earlier, and the solution
that we generated now.
But that difference is due to
the fact that Peterson and
myself used, at that time, a
different solution scheme.
The response solution that we
obtained with the multiple
position analysis is very close
to the response solution
that we calculated using
direct integration.
Now the next analysis that I'd
like to discuss this you
involves the analysis of a
spherical shell subjected to a
uniform pressure.
And that pressure is suddenly
applied as shown down here.
Notice this is a step pressure
constant in time.
The material data of the
shell are given here.
We want to calculate the
elastoplastic response.
And some geometric data
are given here.
Notice the shell was idealized
using 10 8-node
axis-symmetric elements.
It's a spherical shell, so we
use an axis-symmetric model to
model the shell.
We use Newmark integration
with delta and
alpha as given here.
We chose these values because
Nagarajan and Popov had chosen
these same values,
and we wanted to
compare with their solution.
We used 2-by-2 Gauss integration
and a consistent
mass matrix for the problem.
The time step was 10
microseconds, and we used the
total Lagrangian formulation
in the analysis.
The next slide now shows the
response that we predicted.
Here we see the ADINA solution,
a dashed line,
compared with the solution by
Nagarajan and Popov given by
the solid line.
Notice we are plotting here the
apex displacement of the
shell as a function of time.
Now in this particular case,
we use the consistent mass
matrix, 2-by-2 integration,
and specific solution
parameter, and we want to do now
change these parameters in
order to see the effect of
these parameters on the
solution that is predicted.
The next slide now shows again
the apex displacement of the
shell as a function of time,
but using once a consistent
mass matrix, and once using
a lumped mass matrix.
And in this particular case, we
use the trapezoidal rule,
which corresponds to the Newmark
integration with delta
equals 0.5 and alpha
equals 1/4.
Notice that there are only slide
differences between the
lumped mass solution results
and the consistent mass
solution results.
Another parameter that one
might want to vary is the
integration order.
Here we have the response,
using 2-by-2 integration,
which we saw already earlier.
Actually, we didn't quite see
this response earlier, because
earlier we used different delta
and alpha parameters.
Very close to these parameters,
however.
Anyway, here we have the 2-by-2
integration results,
and then we have the 3-by-3
integration results and the
4-by-4 integration
results here.
Very small differences between
these solutions, but it's
interesting to perform these
solutions, and really assure
oneself that there are
small differences.
We know that shells are rather
sensitive structures, and we
want to make sure about the
modeling that we're using for
the representation of these
types of structures.
The next slide now shows the
analysis of a problem for
which we had experimental
results to compare with.
Here we have a pipe, a very
rigid pipe, and a flexible
pipe, a nickel pipe here.
And these pipes, both being
straight, are totally filled
with water.
At the end off this pipe here,
a pulse gun sets off a pulse,
and that pulse travels through
the water, all the way along.
And of course, there's an
interaction between the pipe
and the water.
In other words, it's a fluid
structure interaction problem.
This pipe here is very rigid,
so that we model it as
infinitely rigid.
You will see that just now
on the next slide.
Notice here we have pressure
gauges indicated.
The pressures and the strains
in the pipe, in this nickel
pipe, the flexible pipe, were
measured by the Stanford
Research Institute.
Here we have the nickel
properties, we assume an
elastoplastic material, and
the water properties.
On the next slide now, we see
the pressure pulse as a
function of time.
Of course, this was given
to us for our analysis.
And this slide now shows
the finite element
model that we use.
We used an axis-symmetric
model.
The center line is right here.
And notice that the water here
in the rigid pipe was
represented by 81 elements.
Notice the rigid pipe was
modelled as infinitely rigid,
because these are rollers
on an infinitely rigid
surface, so to say.
Notice here is a nickel pipe
representation, and here we
have water elements again,
and a thin layer of
water elements here.
On the next slide now, we see
the response predicted by
ADINA and the experimental
results, the ADINA response
shown as a solid line and the
experimental result shown as a
dashed line.
Of course, the experimental
results reported by the
Stanford Research Institute.
Notice we are plotting here the
pressure as a function of
time for one of the
pressure stations.
And here you'll see the same
information for another
pressure station, and for
another pressure station, and
one more pressure station--
the pressure stations that I
pointed out to you earlier.
Notice that here finally we
compare the hoop stress
predicted by ADINA with the
experimentally observed hoop
stress as a function of
time at one of the
stations within the pipe.
Notice that for the hoop stress
here, we have four
experimental results
corresponding to the
measurements that were taken at
the north pole, the south
pole, east pole, and west
pole on the pipe.
In the ADINA solution,
of course, we use an
axis-symmetric model, and that
axis-symmetric model only
gives one hoop strain.
And that hoop strain, as you
can see here, lies quite
nicely within the experimental
results obtained by the
Stanford Research Institute.
I should also point out that
the comparison of the ADINA
results with the experimental
results is really very good,
except that we don't pick
up these high-frequency
oscillations that have been
observed in the experiment.
Well, the ADINA finite element
mesh that we used in this
analysis is not able, really,
to represent these
high-frequency oscillations,
and of course, that is
certainly one of the reasons why
we could not hope to pick
these frequency oscillations
up.
This, then, brings me to the
last slide that I wanted to
share with you in this lecture,
and also to the end
of this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.